- Give it a push, give him a push D Rock,
give you a fucking push,
turn this into a gift,
the push all you need is a push.
Gary Vee and this is an
Instagram story takeover,
get ready, full day action, coming.
My big ambition is to be
an all time entrepreneur
by both my success and my career,
but what has become
more evident to people,
I think recently, is also by influencing
as many people as possible
in a positive way,
so that they get theirs.
And that means the person that goes from
the job that they're not excited about,
to making 84,000 sterling
a year being happy
talking about their proper football team
on Instagram and YouTube to the young gal
right now in Sweden, who's gonna start
a 500 million dollar media company.
So I think to be the great
entrepreneur of this generation,
there's clearly the
Bezos's and the Elon Musk's
and the Zuck's, I don't think
I'm gonna be able to create
that kind of wealth, I just want to create
obnoxious amount of wealth
but a billion dollars
and a billion people, I think
puts you above everybody else
and I think that is where
my behavior is right now.
Like why am I doing this podcast?
The state of the union of attention,
in the social media world.
Can our brick road be green?
All right, right it's yellow.
♪ The yellow brick road ♪
I have no idea how many people watch it,
or listen to this, I'm gonna
guess it's a helluva lot
less than the Wall
Street Journal or the BBC
or other people that chase me,
I think in a goal to reach
as many people as possible,
you have to do multiple
things, you have to give back
to people who are actually doing things,
so that they can leverage your name
and get more guests, and
that's what I'm doing here.
- Hey
hello
- Hello
- Oh my god I feel like I know you.
- Yes, how are you?
- Angela, my name's Angela.
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Glad to see you.
- How ya been?
Good.
- Hello, I'm Seagra,
- How are you?
- Hi, I'm Zine,
- Nice to meet you
- Hey, man good to see you, oops sorry
- Hi, I'm Brandon, nice to meet you
- Nice sweater.
- How are you, nice to meet you.
- How are you?
- I'm good, you?
Nice to meet you.
- I'm Matt
- How are you?
- Good
- Good to see ya
- Nice to meet you.
- How are you?
- Nick
- Nice to meet you, Timon
- Timon
- Nice to meet you
- Good to see you, how are you, good
Great,
- And Heidi as well
- Hi
- Nice to meet you
- And also if it's 17
or 1700 or 17,000 every,
you never know which niches
and which different places
where you may catch
somebody, so I'm tirelessly
trying to bring value by
being historically correct
on my points of view on
culture and attention
and business and that's who I am.
Are you building a private
brand or a private label yet?
- Is it a rogue label?
- Correct
- No
- You should, so I think at
this point at that revenue,
the other big debate you
should be having at home
is okay, so the most
important thing for everybody
in this room is the customer,
there is nothing else.
Everything else is secondary, you have
the most important part,
you, at the beginning,
the manufacturers and your suppliers
have the leverage, then
you have the leverage,
so now you have the
leverage, what allows you to
start looking at the
ability for you to create
a signature product that you own forever,
which is much more IP,
which has dramatically
more economic impact long
term, and should 100% be
a parallel highway in your brains
as you continue to try
to go from five to ten,
from 13% margin to 20,
or from 40% margin to 60,
in parallel, not separate, in parallel,
you need to be thinking about,
okay if we're gonna start a private label,
what are we gonna call it?
How are we gonna make it?
What are we gonna make?
Because it's not going to be hyper-fashion
it's going to be iconic,
you're gonna try to be in
the Louis Vuitton,
Cartier, Tiffany business
versus what you're doing now,
but you have the most important asset,
which is the attention
of the young consumer
that equates to five
million dollars in revenue,
which is a meaningful thing.
I'm ambitious about what's going on here,
we're close, closer than you think,
and so please don't let
lack of communication,
be the vulnerability of you
not getting the benefit of it.
'Cause that is it, you're getting close
to going to the next
place, you never thought
you could afford to pay somebody
$150,000 a year to be the lead designer,
but now you could, back to
what are your actual ambitions?
I would argue, that's what
I would do, but that's
because I'm trying to go
here, you need to understand
where you need to be,
you're already at a place--
- That's one of my questions.
- Please, go ahead.
Got one fucking life,
do something about it.
It's all about alternatives,
you know when it's hard
for you and I, doing our
thing, my simple question is,
what would you rather be doing?
Like you really want to go
work for somebody else instead?
We eat shit 24/7, but it's
better than the alternative
and that's how we keep it happy.
See ya.
Great to see you again.
- [Man] Keep buying K-Swiss
- This guy's the best, you're
the best, you're the best.
- Thanks awesome man.
- Nice meeting you.
- Yeah it's such a pleasure,
seriously real talent.
- Thank you, thank you
- All the answers are yes when you're 25.
- Yes
- Stay yes, leave yes.
- Yeah, right
- You understand?
- Yeah
- There's no wrong answer.
- Yeah, yeah
- You're too young.
- I just want to go out there
just do what I want to do.
- So then go.
- But I don't know what it is.
- Go taste, you can afford
to live humbly and taste.
- Right
- Valuing anybody's
opinion besides yourself
is the biggest fucking
mistake of all times.
Fuck his developer friends,
your shit is fucking on point,
go do your thing, don't listen to anybody
but what's in your fucking mind
and your fucking heart, go get yours Zoey.
Tyler did anybody bring me a beanie?
I want put that out there.
- What's up everybody?
- One fucking life do something,
do something like this man
did, listen, learn, go.
- Make it happen guys, make it happen.
Yes thank you very much
- What are you scared of?
Somebody's opinion, mistakes.
The upside's too big.
Gotta try things, you gotta
be committed to one week,
one day, two week jobs,
you just gotta taste shit,
do you have people you admire?
- Yeah
- Copies, jobs, working for the, got it?
Taste, you got it.
What up YouTube?
You guys living or you bullshitting?
Let's go.
Watch out.
- Have the books one day, but I would not
have made that job if it wasn't--
- Go get yours baby stop
fucking listening to anybody
but your head and your fucking heart,
nobody, not your brother,
not your parents,
not society, listen to your
fucking self, go get it.
You gotta be patient about
it, it's a big message.
- Yeah
- Brother I said the same
shit every day for 10 years.
- Self awareness, I want to
teach, I've got kids man.
- Good, good, good
- suicides of business
can do to young people
- Listen , who you talking to,
what the fuck you think I'm up to
- I know man I love it.
- You're scared you're gonna lose
- Okay
- Fuck that
- Do you understand?
- Yeah
- Fuck them.
- Okay, thank you
- You've got it man, just
don't, don't be scared,
it doesn't mean anything,
you're gonna regret it, just go.
- Thank you
- You got it.
How do you get legacy?
- Legacy
- There's only one way
to get legacy my man,
you've got to give more
to them than you take.
The more you give, the less you take,
the more you can have
legacy, do you understand?
- Yeah
- How old are you?
- 23
- That's the biggest thing that scares me,
that you don't realize that you--
- I have my whole life in front of me
- Dude you can do nothing right for
10 years and still be young.
- Yeah that's true.
- No you have to understand,
don't yes me, understand it,
you can fucking, one second,
you can literally, literally
fucking live for the next
10 years, do nothing right,
and fucking win, you're
putting too much pressure
on yourself, you're
either trying to prove it
to somebody or to yourself,
but you gotta slow it down,
you don't know what you
want, nobody fucking knows
what they want at 23, you got time,
you got fucking time baby, you understand?
- Yeah
- You're a kid.
- Decisions, really quickly
- Because I know that I will never know
what the other alternative was
so I'm not crippled by being perfect.
I would DM every single
person in the industry
and people that are winning
on YouTube and Instagram
and offer your services
for free until shit pop.
When you don't have money or
relationships, you have time.
- Yeah
- You have blood, deploy it.
By not worrying about
other people judging me.
- Okay
- I'm not worried about
what my parents think.
- Right, that's it?
- That's it, you can make
every fucking decision
in the world and close out
everybody else's opinion.
First hire should take
away from your luxuries
not put you out of business
- Yeah
- You understand?
- Give up the luxuries
- 100%
The advice is very simple, when you listen
to other people's opinions, you slow down
your fucking destiny, go fucking get it,
one at bat, swing it, swing it.
- 100%
- But I also don't thank
that that one bad experience
means that you can't try again.
- Okay
- Don't don't overreact.
Patience and execution.
Too many people get a little success
and start worrying about
scale, way too prematurely,
you're gonna scale the same way
you got it off the ground
in the first place.
Patience don't worry
about raising capital,
don't worry about that shit, patience
I'm grateful.
- Yeah
- You got a chance
- We got a chance, that's
how I stay motivated.
There's no fucking alternative.
- Thank you
- You know how I tell
people to taste things?
- Yes
- I ran a fucking liquor store,
I ran the e-commerce wine business,
the furthest thing from my fucking mind
was starting a vlog about wine in 2006
but then I tasted something
and it changed my fucking life.
Maybe you're the best surfer in the world,
maybe you're the best caviar
fucking chef on the planet,
you got to try shit
when you're this young.
- For example--
- You're letting everything around you
suck you into something
you don't have to do,
just become great, then talk about it,
only 'cause your ambition's
greater which I commend you on.
You already know that
you're doing loser moves,
so my bigger question
is, you fucking know,
so why would you let yourself do that,
you're gonna be like I
don't know, I don't get it,
but fucking stop, watch
this video every day,
stop, fucking deploy patience.
In the beginning you work for free.
- Yeah
- Then you get all the money.
Execute, inspire through your actions,
not by you trying to convince them,
when you go out and become successful,
on something that isn't
based on convincing them,
and let them see it.
You're stopping every
time you're overwhelmed,
- Yeah, it's simple as that.
- Don't judge yourself
- When you're tired, go to sleep.
Don't judge yourself.
Don't judge yourself man, you're trying.
It's literally basic
shit, like tripling down
on what you're good at, just be honest
with yourself and fucking do.
- Yeah
- It's always that.
- Thanks man
- No one's fucking perfect
easy money is dangerous money.
- [Man] I realize now
that I'm lost a little bit
- No way, you shouldn't be
lost, you're looking backwards.
- What do you mean?
- You're dwelling.
You're worried about what happened.
It's over.
- So what do you think
before you sleep every night?
- That I'm grateful that
everybody I love is alive.
- And when you wake up?
- The same thing.
- Hey can we do the five?
- Yes
(laughing)
good shit.
- Be that on TV
- We will, that's a good
hack, that was well done.
- What up vlog, what up, one life fellas.
Use that chip on your shoulder
as your fucking advantage,
stop dwelling and start focusing.
Life's about a very simple fucking option,
you either do or you don't,
if you're gonna fucking
eat shit under that roof,
you need to put your fucking ear-pods in
and listen to positivity 24/7
to get you through that
shit, do you understand?
When your surroundings are shit,
your inside's gotta be positive.
The fact that you're even here
means your fucking half way home.
- Thanks man.
- Don't you run again.
No fucking choice,
either you're gonna win
or you're gonna lose.
My friend, we're alive, do
you know how special that is?
Stop fucking wasting it, go get yours.
Heather, get the fuck up, get the fuck up,
this is your at bat, we're so blessed
to even wake the fuck up, get the fuck up!
- Marketing to three to eight year olds,
I know you're things usually at
teenagers and decision makers.
- You're marketing to the mothers
of three to eight year olds?
- Yeah, yeah
- Yeah
- So that's what I'm trying to, yeah okay.
- See Rock I'm on fire.
You're never gonna know what
would have happened otherwise.
- That's true
- You're just bullshitting
and wasting, pick one.
- Do I just keep doing shit
and then I know what
doesn't work, what works.
- Just go.
Couldn't hear it?
I don't believe you, I don't believe you.
Write the Avi up.
Make it lower Avi.
One life, do something about it,
fucking put in the
work, stop bullshitting.
- I love you dad.
- You know what to do.
- Yeah
- You got time
- I got time
- Go try
We're very upset with you
Kim that you're not here.
- Where are you?
- Kim where the fuck are you?
Put in the fucking work
and shut the fuck up.
I'm 20 years older than you,
and I feel just like you,
you've got time, crushing it
is actually more about patience
than you think, be thoughtful, be smart,
I've met kids here today that made 100K
in two minutes in bitcoin and lost it
three months later, he asked me why?
- No
he's got it
- He's coming, he's coming, he's coming.
- He asked me why and I told him
because fast money is dangerous money.
Be patient.
- The older young people out there,
are trying to figure out their stuff,
wanting to make it
happen, what do they do?
- The problem is is you
let somebody else's opinion
dictate your behavior, while
you're figuring it out,
let me, let me break the
news to you, 99% of people
in their 20's, didn't know
what the fuck they're doing,
99% of people in their 90's,
don't know what the fuck they're doing,
stop judging yourself, everybody
else is doing it for you,
just taste, try, learn,
hustle, do the right thing,
like fuck, just work hard and be patient,
and don't worry that you've
gotta figure it out now
to stick it to your older brother
because he's more
successful, or your parents
that said you'd never,
the only people that win,
are the people that win
when the score is over,
everybody in their 20's is trying to win
the first quarter, it's
a four quarter game.
It's a fucking marathon,
people think I fucking
did this yesterday, this has
taken my whole fucking life.
While you're complaining,
I'm taking your shit,
remember that.
Thank you, means the world to me, Sasha V.
Where are you Barb, what the fuck.
You got to put out great
content, you got to be patient,
you got to DM people,
- Okay, I watched your video today.
- Say it every day, the problem is
you want to get too big too fast
- How long do you
recommend taking, roughly?
- Maybe your whole fucking life.
- You just gotta do it.
- Brother when you start
asking questions how long
it's gonna take, you'll
never get there, ever
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's what
our passion is, doing it.
- It's about loving the
process of getting there.
I can't wait to fucking win in mainland,
do you know why I love mainland China?
Not because it has so many people,
it's because nobody
knows who the fuck I am.
I love the process.
- Sure, and that's what
the future is, isn't it?
- Forget about the future, you're trying
to get too big too fast.
- Thank you, yeah
- Which is why you won't get big.
- Okay
you got me real, don't it.
- It's the truth, your 19
Rod, you could fucking do it
for nine years, be 28, be younger than
fucking shitty D Rock
over here and fucking win.
- I know, he's younger, he's younger.
All right, see ya.
Yeah man,
it's all for the taking.
- I'm so happy that--
- Stop dwelling and start taking,
stop fucking dwelling and start taking.
Respect your pops.
- You hear that?
- You like that part?
- I love that part.
- And number two, respect yourself more.
- Yes, yep there gonna do great things.
- Start listening to fewer voices.
- Sure
- Greatest era to be making music ever.
Very simply because there's
no fucking middle man
stopping you, you're fucking
dwelling about algorithms
and Spotify this, it's
the fucking greatest era,
get yours, fucking make the
music, put it out, get it.
One life do something about it.
Tell you things like I do, I have empathy
that you think I'm 24
but this is what I feel,
respect it, address it, and
then you can do anything.
Best way to be awesome,
is give more to others
and be patient, that's how you get it.
Hey
- Seriously thank you for everything bro.
- You're welcome bro, see you guys later,
take care, thank you for coming.
So stuff and all that
- Yeah
- And I'll take it from there, okay.
- Alright
- Bye bye
- Thank you
- Great to see you.
- See you'll get there in the end
- In the end baby, Johnny
you better be patient.
- Just four words for my
friend, moments we live for.
- Johnny, listen to me,
moments we life for,
everybody forget about this
clip I'm not giving to him,
use this to put pressure
on him to be patient,
that's what he actually needs.
- I'm an aspiring writer
as I told you, and I come,
I've started, I'm sort of
coming out of depression,
I'm forcing myself out of the rut.
- Good
- And I'm using vlogging and documenting
because I still have I feel like,
what you say is true you know, I do know
whether I'm doing it
right, I feel like vlogging
is the way and documenting
right now is the way,
I totally agree with everything
and I hope that it will
start to generate income
so I can do and do something with it.
And I also want to,
there's two ways I think
the world can change, right, one is
healthcare and technology,
science and technology--
- Brother the world changing is too heady,
the world is the world, do you
know how good the world is?
The world doesn't need to change.
Humans have had it good
forever, we're still here,
the world's great, our perspectives
on the world is the key,
however you were raised, the chemicals,
the circumstance, put you here now.
What's incredible is that you
have the ambition to tweak it,
that, listen a lot of
times when I see my crew
or the people I jam with,
I'm already optimistic
about you because you're trying
to twist whatever's not working.
You understand that right?
- Yeah
- You understand that
you can't fix the way
you were parented where you
grew up and what happened.
- I'm just trying to like move forward.
- I get it.
- But i just don't know if
I'm doing the right thing
even though I feel like it is.
- The good news is, whatever
you did in the early part,
is what's making you insecure
of whether it's the right thing,
the more you do pattern recognition,
the more you do, the more you
do, you become more of it.
Like listen the biggest thing
I would tell all of you,
I've never actually said this,
the biggest thing I'm observing right now,
is what my mom did for me,
I'm in a small way doing for others.
Like it's actually quite scary,
I have to think about
what the truth is here,
it's just like, what would happen
if you just listened to
positivity and optimism?
I think so right, listen, listen, listen,
I'm worried that it gets into delusion
and I think the reason
people resonate with me,
is I'm not making it likes it's the secret
and everything's going to be
okay, I'm like no it's hard,
it's work, you might
suck, but all you need
is more optimism and
positivity and execution.
You're allowing, you were judged,
by something, you know and
that's what you have to break.
Right, that's what it did my man,
you were judged and that's what
you're imposing on yourself,
you need to break that, listen,
eight out of 10 times you were
judged by a parent or both,
two out of 10 times you were
judged by your environment.
You know what you
understand, you just need
to keep having this talk,
with me over and over.
You know?
- Yeah, I just, sometimes
I feel like I just got it
I don't know, 'cause for
like writing is tough.
- You know what's funny,
you know what's funny?
It's not writing is tough,
making video's is tough,
starting a travel stuff is tough,
being 24 is tough, like
it's tough for all of us.
- Yeah I know it is, I'm not, I'm not--
- Guys I'm judged every
day, guys, go read,
go read the reviews to
Crush It! on Amazon,
go read them, go read the one star reviews
of how I'm a snake oil salesman
and I'm a piece of shit.
- Yeah they think you're a coke head.
- Yeah, fucking, I can't take two Advil
without being unconscious,
people think I'm on
Adderall and coke every minute,
like it's happening every day.
- [Woman] When you were doing the Q and A,
people up here were like he's
just running so you should--
- Right, I get it, but
like I don't expect them
to take the time to figure out who I am,
I'm not mad at them, I'm empathetic,
I get that it's hard, I
know, I know I'm confusing.
But anyway dude, you got judged by parent,
you just need to go to
your positive mindset.
- Thanks man
- You're welcome, I love you.
Guys I wish you guys well,
see you guys, good night everyone.
(gentle music)